it's been so nice you know people
dropping by one of the amazing things
about being in New York is we've had all
these great local celebrities drop by to
say hello it's been such a treat yoo-hoo
counting did someone say a local
celebrity no God no God no ladies and
gentleman I don't expect you remember
him but this is Pizza rat that's right
New York's biggest star nine million
views on YouTube no autographs please
all right listen guess what I got news
treat Pete's right no one wants your
autograph anymore okay and I
specifically told you not to come by
this week how did you even get here when
you're a big star like Pizza rat you got
a key to the city
yes just kidding I crawled up through a
toilet all right sorry if I scared you
Andy
give it a little you did by the way you
uh you should really get that thing
checked out all right listen up it's a
mole I told you it's already sold about
pizza wait this thing is devolving and
now look the sketch what the fake rat is
devolved it when you drag that pizza
slice down the subway stairs they loved
it but that was over a year ago it's old
news now no no you just haven't see my
new material check it out no no you
don't have to do this well familiar with
your act Pizza rat no no no hate it no
I'm bagel
[Applause]
really not as easy as a slice of pizza
is it it's a totally different shape
anyway that's the difference okay you
knows you carried the pizza slice down
the stairs what's the big difference
different it's really different all
right all right but I'm telling you the
bagel just feels like more of the same
okay okay okay
tough crowd all right guys let me just
jump to my big closer okay big closer
laser diamond I'm sorry about this this
is a huge waste of time I asked him not
I begged him not to come he shouldn't be
here
get out your cellphone's we're going
viral come on
[Applause]
you're embarrassing yourself Pizza right
you had a good run but face it it's over
you're done don't you dance either I was
the toast of the town the great rats
beat a call no one called you no one
called you the great rats B no one ever
sure I even made a sex tape with Chelsea
Handler do not roll the clip
please Conan Conan I gotta get back in
the game I need to clicks I need the
clicks all right Pizza rat you're
sounding desperate now it's just getting
sad
ah you're right Who am I fooling I
should just go back to grad school Oh
God go for pizza rat uh-huh yeah that's
great news Conan I just booked a big
role on Law & Order SVU yeah
lotor SVU yeah I'm gonna be dragging a
dead guy's eyeball down some subway
stairs so long losers I'm gonna be
famous forever all right everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry this is the worst prop I've
ever seen
what's that I take the ride
we flew this all the way from Los
Angeles this thing had its own seat on
the plane my apologies we'll take a
break
think about when you come back Tracy
Morgan's here
you